Вітаю, друзі!
З вами Сергій Колебошин.
І ми на уроці фізики 10 класу.
Тему уроку ви можете
побачити тут на екрані.
Перш ніж ми будемо
говорити про тему уроку,
давайте згадаємо, з яким
багажем ми підійшли до цього уроку.
В рамках якої теми ми працюємо,
що ми вивчаємо і що нам знадобиться тут,
вивчаючи тему нашого уроку.
А потім перейдемо - чому саме ці
теми є актуальними для нас на сьогодні.
Тож я нагадаю, що ми з вами
вивчаємо молекулярно-кінетичну теорію.
І ми з вами записали
основне рівняння МКТ -
це рівняння, яке поєднує мікропараметри.
Згадайте, що таке мікропараметр.
Слово мікро каже само за себе -
це параметри, які
характеризують окремі молекули.
Наприклад, маса,
швидкість молекули і так далі.
І макропараметри - це параметри,
які характеризують тіло в цілому.
Наприклад, температура тіла і
ми ввели цей термін температура.
Не дивуйтесь, ви кажете: я
температуру знаю з дитинства.
Температуру з фізичної точки зору ми ввели
саме в молекулярно-кінетичній теорії.
Наприклад, тиск і об'єм.
Я нагадаю, що основним рівнянням
молекулярно-кінетичної теорії
є якраз рівняння, яке поєднує
мікро і макро параметри.
Подивіться макропараметр.
Тиск ідеального газу - ще
одне важливе нагадування.
В молекулярно-кінетичній
теорії, тут в 10 класі,
ми з вами працюємо тільки
з моделлю ідеального газу.
Згадайте, що таке ідеальний газ?
Ідеальний газ - це газ
взаємодії між молекулами,
якого ми нехтуємо, немає
потенціальної енергії взаємодії,
є тільки кінетична енергія їхнього руху.
Це маса однієї молекули,
це концентрація молекул і
середня квадратична швидкість.
Справа в тому - я тільки що вже згадав -
що молекули рухаються
з різними швидкостями.
Але для того, щоб нам було
зручно записати рівняння,
ми кажемо про середню швидкість
і середню кінетичну енергію.
Нагадаю ще декілька речей.
Ми з вами записали,
яким є зв'язок між цією
середньою кінетичною
енергією молекул і температурою.
3/2k - це стала Больцмана
на Т, температура абсолютна.
Нагадаю, що ми тут працюємо в абсолютній
шкалі температур, шкалі Кельвіна.
А 3/2k – це, фактично,
курс обміну валют, курс
переведення від температури
до кінетичної енергії.
Ми з вами записали
так зване рівняння стану
для ідеального газу, або
рівняння Менделєєва-Клапейрона.
Тиск помножити на
об'єм - це маса вказує на
молярну масу,
на R (універсальна газова стала)
це теж певний такий курс
обміну валют, на температуру Т.
Ось ці три рівняння були основними
і ми, в тому числі, сьогодні
будемо їх використовувати.
Про що ми будемо з вами говорити.
Нагадаю, що ми з вами
вивчаємо теплові явища.
Молекулярно-кінетична теорія класно
працює у випадку ідеального газу.
Вона не буде описувати, наприклад,
рідини або, наприклад, тверді тіла.
Є певні нюанси із застосуванням
молекулярно-кінетичної теорії,
в тому числі, і для пари.
Тому зараз, ось ці декілька
уроків які ми будемо вивчати,
ми попрацюємо з описанням з теплової точки
зору різних агрегатних станів речовини:
Пара, рідина та тверді тіла.
Та почнемо саме з пари.
Ми сьогодні з вами поговоримо
про випаровування і конденсацію.
А більшою мірою не просто поговоримо,
а згадаємо і те що, у вас було в 8 класі.
Поговоримо про дуже важливі поняття:
«насичена та ненасичена пара».
Якщо казати з прикладної точки зору,
то ми з вами сьогодні поговоримо,
як зробити чашку чаю більш
такою прохолодною для того,
щоб можна було пити цей чай.
Як ми користуємось блюдцем, як працює фен.
Поговоримо, в тому числі, про те,
яким чином відбуваються
процеси випаровування,
конденсації та інші
процеси, пов'язані з парою.
Тож беріть в руки ваші
олівці, ручки, зошити.
Нагадую, що ми з вами, не
зважаючи на те, що ви дивитесь
online, ми однаково
знаходимось на уроці фізики.
Тому беріть зошити, підручники.
Якщо у вас збереглись зошити за 8
клас, вони вам сьогодні знадобляться.
Записуйте тему уроку.
А ми з вами переходимо
безпосередньо до роботи з цією темою.
Отже, ми з вами говоримо
про утворення пари.
Фізичною мовою - пароутворення.
Давайте згадаємо, в 8
класі ми з вами говорили
про те, що пароутворення є двох видів.
Пароутворення може відбуватися
за рахунок механізму випаровування,
а другий механізм - це кипіння.
Це тема наступного уроку.
Обидва цих способи відомі вам.
Давайте згадаємо, яким чином
відбувається випаровування,
від чого залежить
швидкість випаровування і які
є ще особливості,
пов'язані із випаровуванням.
Давайте намалюємо умовну якусь
посудину, в ній знаходиться рідина.
Більшою мірою ми з вами
говоритимемо про пару водяну.
Тому, якщо я кажу рідина, а
іноді вода, все одно ми розуміємо,
що йдеться про одні й ті
ж процеси в різних рідинах.
Дивимось на дошку.
Ось тут у нас вода, тут є молекули,
давайте молекули будуть червоні.
Вони рухаються.
Звичайно, у них є кінетична
енергія і вони взаємодіють.
На відміну від того, що є тут.
Певні молекули, які
знаходяться біля поверхні,
можуть володіти достатньою
кінетичною енергією,
для того, щоб подолати взаємодію
навколишніх молекул і вийти назовні.
Ми кажемо, що молекула перейшла в
газову фазу, відбулося випаровування.
Які це будуть молекули?
Давайте з вами згадаємо,
якщо в нас молекула долає,
взаємодіє з іншими
молекулами, вона виконує роботу.
Що це за робота?
Напрям переміщення сюди, а взаємодія туди.
Це робота буде від'ємна, це робота
по виходу цієї молекули з рідини.
Така робота називається – робота виходу.
Дивимось на екран.
Від чого залежить ця робота виходу?
Давайте подумаємо.
Чи буде робота виходу однаковою,
якщо це буде вода або ртуть, або спирт?
Звичайно, що там взаємодія різна
і тому робота виходу буде різною.
Робота виходу характеризує
те, яка рідина випаровується.
Давайте згадаємо механіку.
Ми знаємо, що робота дорівнює
зміні кінетичної енергії тіла.
Запишемо.
Робота - це зміна, дельта
кінетичної енергії тіла.
Тому роботу виходу зможуть
виконати тільки ті молекули,
кінетична енергія яких достатньо
велика для того, щоб вийти.
Чи всі молекули зможуть вийти?
Звичайно ні.
Які молекули виходять?
Ті, які рухаються найшвидше.
Ми пам'ятаємо, що не всі
молекули мають однакову швидкість.
Швидкість у нас різна.
Найшвидші молекули покидають рідину.
Тож давайте, розуміючи цей факт,
сформулюємо що таке випаровування.
Запишемо визначення.
Дивимось на екран.
Випаровування – пароутворення,
яке відбувається з поверхні рідини.
Іноді кажуть - з вільної поверхні рідини,
бо умовно можна казати, що це теж якась
поверхня, але вона
взаємодіє тут із посудиною.
Зараз ми з вами поговоримо,
від чого залежить
швидкість випаровування,
точніше, згадаємо – від чого
залежить швидкість випаровування.
І після цього ми ще поговоримо про
певні особливості цього випаровування.
Працюємо далі.
Від чого залежить швидкість випаровування?
Знову рекомендую згадати 8 клас.
Або просто згадати свій життєвий досвід.
Що ми робимо для того, щоб
випаровування відбувалось швидше.
Що я роблю для того, щоб
цей чай прохолов швидше?
Є декілька способів.
Ми про всі ці способи поговоримо.
Швидкість випаровування залежить від:
Записуємо в зошит:
Фактор №1.
Що ви робите для того, щоб
цей чай швидше прохолов.
Перший спосіб – дуємо.
Швидкість вітру або відведення
повітря від поверхні рідини.
Швидкість відведення повітря.
А що ще можна робити?
Друге:
Ми беремо блюдце і наливаємо
чай сюди, трохи чекаємо
і розуміємо, що чай досить
швидко буде остигати.
Тож, що ми змінили у
порівнянні з цим стаканчиком?
Ми збільшили площу поверхні.
Збільшилась площа поверхні –
більше шансів для
молекули вискочити з рідини.
Друге - це площа поверхні
Від чого ще залежить
швидкість випаровування?
Ми пам'ятаємо, що
коли чай дуже гарячий, то
випаровування відбувається
набагато швидше,
ніж коли він вже прохолов і його
температура наблизилась до кімнатної.
Фактор 3 - Температура Т.
- І, нарешті, четвертий фактор.
Що було, якби сюди була налита
не вода, а якась інша рідина?
Давайте поміркуємо.
Згадаємо дезінфекційний розчин,
ви бризнули на долоню свою і він
буде випаровуватись набагато
швидше, якщо б це була просто вода.
А він на основі спирту.
Різні рідини випаровуються
з різною швидкістю.
Спирт або ефір - набагато швидше,
ніж вода, а ртуть – набагато повільніше.
Тобто, залежить від роду рідини.
Записуємо.
Фактор 4 - яка це рідина
Ми знаємо, що характеристикою
буде саме робота виходу,
тобто у нас є математична
характеристика або фізична характеристика,
яка характеризує
залежність від роду рідини.
Давайте з вами домовимось про наступне:
Коли ми будемо з вами
говорити про випаровування,
будемо говорити про випаровування
з одиниці поверхні рідини
з квадратного метру, або
квадратного сантиметру,
в залежності від контексту задач.
Тому для нас цей фактор
№2 не буде важливим.
Ми з вами розмірковуємо про
випаровування з одиниці поверхні.
Наступне про що ми з вами домовимось, те,
що фактор №1 в нас не буде
фактором, про який ми будемо міркувати.
Тобто швидкість відведення цих
молекул для нас не буде зараз важливою,
ми не будемо враховувати
що є певний вітер.
Ми будемо говорити про
якусь стаціонарну ситуацію.
Ніщо не відводить ці молекули.
Тому цей фактор теж для нас не є важливим.
Для нас будуть важливими два фактори:
Температура рідини і те, яка це рідина.
Якщо ми знаємо яка це
рідина, наприклад, вода,
то для нас буде важливим
тільки температура.
І я буду далі говорити, що
швидкість випаровування
залежить від температури
для даної рідини.
Це можна записати: Швидкість випаровування
залежить від температури для даної рідини.
Ще одна важлива особливість випаровування.
Давайте про неї теж поговоримо.
Дивимось на дошку.
Малюємо посудину, знов є вода,
або інша рідина і ми пам'ятаємо,
що в нас найспритніші
молекули можуть вийти назовні.
Я сказав термін "найспритніші молекули,
тобто середня швидкість
молекул, які лишаються в рідині.
Вона що робить?
Давайте поміркуємо.
Проста така підказка.
Уявіть собі, що з вашого класу піднялось
і вийшло в коридор 5 найвищих учнів.
Що буде з середнім ростом вашого класу?
Звичайно, він зменшується.
Що буде із середньою швидкістю
молекул, які знаходяться в рідині?
Звичайно, що вона буде знижуватись.
Якщо ми кажемо про
середню, то тут не обов'язково
казати про вектор, будемо
просто казати про середню.
Дивимось на дошку.
Тобто звідси витікає, що зменшується
середня кінетична енергія молекул.
Що таке середня кінетична енергія молекул?
Згадайте з чого ми починали урок.
Ми з вами записали формулу,
яка нагадує, що середня кінетична
енергія молекул із точністю
до констант - це і є температура.
Тобто звідси витікає, що
температура рідини буде зменшуватись.
Під час випаровування
температура рідини зменшується.
Запишіть цю фразу: Під час випаровування
температура рідини зменшується.
Ми це добре відчуваємо, коли ми влітку
виходимо з моря і перший
час нам трохи холодно,
тому що випаровуються
ті краплини морської
води, які є на нас, і
температура зменшується.
Для того, щоб температура під
час випаровування не зменшувалась,
нам треба підводити якусь
певну кількість теплоти до рідини.
Ми можемо казати з вами про
питому теплоту пароутворення.
Ми про це з вами розмірковували у 8 класі.
Тож цей факт ми зафіксували.
Давайте зараз поговоримо, а якою є доля
молекул, які випарувались,
які знаходяться тут?
Вони знаходяться в газоподібному
стані і рухаються безперервно, хаотично.
Ну, по-перше, ці молекули
можуть чинити тиск, зрозуміло.
Молекули водяної пари
можуть чинити такий саме тиск,
який можуть чинити молекули
повітря або іншого газу.
Я нагадаю, що цей тиск ми можемо з
вами розрахувати за формулою, наприклад,
Дивимось на дошку
Це формула, якою ми сьогодні
неодноразово будемо користуватись.
А якщо вони рухаються
безперервно, хаотично, то може
статися таке, що вона, ця
молекула, повернеться до рідини.
І ми кажемо про зворотній
до пароутворення процес -
процес конденсації,
переходу з газоподібного стану до рідкого.
Це визначення ми теж записували в
8 класі, але раджу вам його записати.
Конденсація - перехід з
газоподібного стану до рідкого.
Я нагадаю, що випаровування може
відбуватись не обов'язково з рідкої фази.
Є випаровування, яке
відбувається і з твердого тіла.
Згадайте, ви чули про такий термін
сухий лід, це тверда фаза - в нас СО2.
І цей сухий лід одразу випаровується,
тобто такий процес зветься сублімація -
перехід, випаровування,
яке відбувається з твердої
фази одразу в газоподібну,
минаючи рідку фазу.
Але більшою мірою ми зіткаємось з
переходом рідини в газоподібний стан.
Тому ми кажемо випаровування з рідини.
Ось це основні такі терміни,
які нам треба знати для того,
щоб перейти до
наступного аспекту, дуже для
нас важливого і нового
у порівнянні з 8 класом.
Поговоримо про насичену пару.
Давайте проведемо
наступний такий експеримент.
Уявіть собі посудину.
У нас їх буде чотири.
Тобто одна посудина, з якою ми
будемо робити певні маніпуляції.
Перший випадок.
Дивимось на дошку.
Посудина, в ній є рідина
(вода) і вона закрита
поршнем, який щільно
прилягає до поверхні.
Далі робимо наступне.
Беремо цей поршень і підіймаємо догори.
Давайте будемо
дивитись, що відбувається з
рідиною, тим більше,
що ми все про це знаємо.
Поршень підняли вгору,
що почне робити вода?
Вірно - випаровуватись.
Тому рівень води, я трохи меншим
намалюю, вода починає випаровуватись.
Тобто найбільш швидкі
молекули в нас виходять назовні.
Один, два, три - умовні такі стрілочки.
В нас з'являється певний
тиск, але давайте поміркуємо,
до яких пір будуть ці
молекули випаровуватись.
Зрозуміло, що в нас будуть
молекули, які повертаються до рідини,
тобто відбувається зворотній процес.
Процес конденсації.
І в певний момент
часу ми дійдемо до ситуації,
коли кількість молекул за
одиницю часу, наприклад,
за одну секунду, які виходять
з рідини, буде дорівнювати
кількості молекул, які за одиницю
часу повертаються до рідини.
Встановиться рівновага, іноді
кажуть – динамічна рівновага.
Динамічна рівновага –
це ситуація, коли кількість молекул,
які виходять з рідини за одиницю часу,
дорівнюють кількості молекул, які за ту
ж одиницю часу повертаються до рідини.
Якщо буде збільшуватись
кількість молекул, які виходять,
то відразу ймовірність повернення
молекул в рідку фазу збільшується.
Дуже швидко відбудеться
таке, що кількість підрівняється.
Тому за якоїсь температури
Т1 в нас тут буде тиск Р1,
але це не просто тиск
Р1 – це тиск насиченої пари.
Насичена це пара, яка знаходиться в стані
динамічної рівноваги із своєю рідиною.
Перше визначення.
Запишіть це, будь ласка
Динамічна рівновага – кількість молекул,
які за одиницю часу виходять з рідини,
дорівнює кількості молекул, які за
одиницю часу повертаються в рідину.
Друге визначення.
Пара в стані динамічної рівноваги
із власною рідиною – насичена пара.
Водяна пара, яка
навкруги нас тут в повітрі,
теж може дійти до стану насиченої пари.
Ми про це поговоримо трохи
сьогодні, більше – на наступних уроках.
Зараз за цих умов, в яких ми записуємо
урок, вона не є в стані насиченої пари.
Ми теж визначимо, чому я
так швидко про це дізнався.
Третій експеримент.
Малюємо посудину.
В нас є рідина і я трохи
цей поршень посуну вниз.
Температура лишається такою самою Т1.
Що в нас буде відбуватися тут?
Звичайно, процес
випаровування ніхто не відміняв.
Давайте згадаємо, від того факту,
що я посунув поршень вниз,
але температура лишається
такою самою Т1, чи зміниться
швидкість випаровування?
Ми з вами на початку уроку казали,
що швидкість випаровування
визначається температурою.
Температуру я не змінив, тому швидкість
випаровування лишається такою самою.
Так, звичайно, в перший
момент часу, оскільки ми
збільшили концентрацію
молекул в перший момент часу.
Кількість молекул, які конденсуються,
тобто повертаються в рідину,
може бути більшою,
але дуже швидко, навіть
швидше, якщо ми кажемо
про об'єм цієї посудини,
там пару літрів, швидше
ніж я цю фразу сказав,
знов кількість молекул,
які повертаються, буде
дорівнювати кількості
молекул, які виходять.
На відміну від ідеального газу, коли
зменшивши об'єм, ми збільшуємо тиск,
тиск тут буде такий самий,
як тиск насиченої пари Р1.
Запишіть.
Тиск насиченої пари
не залежить від об'єму.
Він залежить від концентрації,
але концентрація
підрівняється саме за рахунок того,
що темп випаровування
лишається таким самим.
Він визначається температурою.
Четвертий експеримент.
Давайте з вами не
будемо зменшувати об'єм, а
збільшимо температуру і
подивимось, що відбувається.
Тож, четверта посудина, знов рідина.
Об'єм ми не змінюємо, ось це наш поршень,
але я, наприклад, зігріваю цю воду,
тобто температура Т2
більша за температуру Т1.
Давайте подивимось,
що буде відбуватися тут.
Тут у нас рідина.
В нас температура збільшилась.
Що буде відбуватись з
темпом випаровування?
Ми знаємо, що він буде збільшуватись.
Більша температура - швидше випаровується.
Я це зображу не трьома
стрілочками, а чотирма.
Це уявна в нас така ілюстрація.
В перші декілька секунд, в нас
буде ситуація, коли кількість молекул,
які випаровуються, трохи
більша за кількість молекул,
які конденсуються, які
повертаються до рідини.
Але ми з вами знову кажемо, що досить
швидко встановиться динамічна рівновага.
Це буде вже нова динамічна
рівновага, бо ці кількості
будуть різні, але це однаково
буде динамічна рівновага.
Я це намалюю чотирма стрілочками.
Ми з вами отримаємо
ситуацію, коли тиск насиченої
пари в цьому випадку
буде вже не Р1, а Р2.
Поміркуйте, більший тиск за Р1 чи менший?
Давайте, скажемо, температура збільшилась.
Згадаємо формулу.
Дивимось на екран.
Ми з вами цю формулу
записували на початку уроку.
Температура збільшилась,
тому тиск точно збільшиться.
Але є надважливий фактор –
окрім температури збільшилась
і концентрація молекул.
Тут ми бачимо, що їх більше.
Тому в нас тиск збільшиться
більше, ніж якби це був ідеальний газ.
Тиск збільшиться суттєво, якщо температура
збільшиться в два рази, наприклад,
то тиск збільшиться набагато більше.
Записуємо, що тиск Р2 більший за Р1.
Зараз у нас остання частина уроку –
коли ми поміркуємо і побудуємо графік
залежності тиску насиченої
пари від температури.
Останній для нас крок – це побудувати
графік тієї залежності,
про яку ми говорили,
– залежності тиску насиченої
пари від температури.
З чим ми будемо порівнювати цю залежність?
Ми будемо її порівнювати
із тиском ідеального газу.
Ми побудуємо два графіка -
графік залежності тиска і
графік залежності концентрації.
Ми щойно говорили, що
цей параметр змінюється.
Готуємо два графіка.
Тут в нас буде вісь
ординат, тут вісь абсцис.
Тут ми будемо працювати
із концентрацією, а тут
з тиском, тут ми будемо
підкладати температуру.
Давайте з вами побудуємо
цей графік для ідеального газу.
Ідеальний газ в нас буде, наприклад,
блакитним кольором, а
насичена пара буде червона.
Чи змінюється концентрація ідеального
газу, якщо ми збільшуємо температуру?
Якщо ми не додаємо додатковий якийсь
газ, то концентрація змінюватись не буде.
Тому для ідеального газу це буде
виглядати якимось таким чином.
Поміркуйте, чому я тут пунктиром
малював, а не одразу прямою лінією?
Потім в коментарях я
дам правильну відповідь.
Тож, ідеальний газ в нас залежність така.
Що відбувається з насиченою парою?
Якщо ми збільшуємо
температуру, ми розуміємо,
що концентрація молекул
пари збільшується.
Суттєво збільшується, якось таким
чином будемо малювати червоний колір.
Вона збільшується.
До яких пір вона буде
збільшуватись, чи до нескінченності?
Звичайно, ні.
Якщо ми повернемось до тих уявних
експериментів, які малювали, ми можемо
зрозуміти, що колись вся вода випарується
і в нас вже не буде насиченої пари,
в нас пара стане ненасиченою,
якась така температура Т і далі в нас
буде ненасичена пара, для неї в
нас не буде змінюватись концентрація.
Це в нас пара.
Тут в нас пара насичена,
а тут в нас пара ненасичена.
Переходимо до найважливішого.
До залежності тиску від
температури. Що для газу?
Для газу дуже просто.
В нас змінюється тиск тільки за
рахунок зміни температури - ізохора.
Це пряма лінія з математичної точки зору,
яка проходить через начало координат.
Давайте її намалюємо.
Це для газу.
Повторюю - ізохора.
Що у нас для пари?
Дивіться, в нас тиск зростає, тому що є
два чинники - температура і концентрація.
Тому він буде зростати як?
Він буде зростати не
лінійно, а зверхлінійно.
Якимось таким чином.
І знову до тієї точки, в якій
насичена пара вже буде ненасиченою.
Далі буде відбуватись
лінійне зростання таким
чином, щоб проходило
через начало координат.
Це в нас пара.
Це насичена,
а це – ненасичена.
Давайте поговоримо про ось цю температуру.
Для нас важливо.
Будемо рухатись в зворотному напрямку.
Уявіть собі, що в нас є ненасичена
пара, наприклад, в цій кімнаті.
Я починаю зменшувати її
температуру. Наприклад, стає холодніше.
І в якийсь момент ми дійдемо до ситуації,
коли ненасичена пара стане насиченою.
Що буде відбуватись далі?
Залишок цієї пари, оскільки вона
вже насичена, буде що робити?
Вірно.
Конденсуватись, будуть
утворюватись невеличкі краплинки.
Як ми називаємо такі краплинки,
які ми бачимо зранку, коли
температура зменшується і
ненасичена пара стає насиченою?
Це роса.
Тому температура, за якою
ненасичена пара стає насиченою,
так і зветься – точка роси.
Запишіть це визначення:
Точка роси – це температура, за
якої ненасичена пара стає насиченою.
Наостанок я продемонструю
залежність тиску насиченої пари
і густини насиченої пари від температури.
Ми бачимо, що за фіксованих
температур, це фіксовані значення.
Наприклад, за температури 4 градуса
Цельсія,
в нас тиск насиченої пари 0,81 кПа
а в повітрі, якщо пара була б насиченою,
густина водяної пари в повітрі
була б 6,4 г/м3
Ми будемо багато
працювати з цією таблицею.
Друзі, що ми з вами сьогодні зробили?
Ми зробили перший крок у
вивчення властивостей пари.
Далі ми поговоримо про
кипіння, вологість повітря і
зрозуміємо – чому нам в
сиру погоду так некомфортно.
Зрозуміємо – чому врожай
залежить від вологості повітря.
І дуже багато інших цікавих тем.
Урок закінчено.
Рекомендоване домашнє завдання ви побачите
в першому коментарі до цього відео.
А я з вами із нетерпінням чекаю
нової зустрічі. На все добре, бувайте!